قاده السعوديه خفضا طوعيا منسقا للانتاج
النفطي من دول داخل اوبيك ومن خارجها
باجمالي مليون و660 الف برميل يوميا بدءا
من مايو المقبل وحتى نهايه العام الجاري
وفسرت الخطوه بانها اجراء احترازي لتحقيق
الاستقرار والتوازن في اسواق الخام وفي
التفاصيل ستخفض السعوديه انتاجها من النفط
ب 500 الف برميل يوميا فيما ستخفض
الامارات الانتاج ب 144 الف برميل يوميا
والكويت ب128 الف برميل يوميا كما اعلنت
الجزائر خفضا طوعيا بثمانيه واربعين الف
برميل يوميا كذلك اعلن العراق انه سيخفض
الانتاج ب 211,000 برميل يوميا فيما اعلنت
سلطنه عمان خفضا باربعين الف برميل يوميا
كذلك اعلنت كازاخستان عن خفض طوعي
بانتاجها
الف برميل يوميا فيما اعلنت الجابون عن
خفض بثمانيه الاف برميل يوميا وفي موسكو
اعلن نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه الكزند
نوفاك ان بلاده ستمدد خفضا طوعيا بانتاجها
من النفط بواقع 500 الف برميل يوميا حتى
نهايه العمل جاري من متوسط مستوى الانتاج
وفقا لتقييمات مصادر ثانويه لشهر فبراير
وسيضاف هذا الخفض الى الخفض الذي اعلنه
تحالف اوبيكلاس في اكتوبر 2022
والذي قضى بخفض بمليوني برميل يوميا حتى
نهايه العام الجاري هذا وكانت اسعار النفط
قد تراجعت الشهر الماضي الى ادنى مستوى
لها في 15 شهرا بالقرب من 70 دولار
للبرميل وفى ازمه المصارف الامريكيه وتدخل
الحكومه السويسريه لانقاذ كريدي سويس مايا
جريديني العربيه